because I have with before Wagenknecht
bears responsibility together,
i was with her at the party stand,
when the left one was created,
together with her husband Oscar Lauri
um,
i fought for this broad left,
i didn't fight for the narrow left and uh,
I take note of um,
that um,
Sarah,
who is from Thuringia,
who was born in Jena,
I have invited
to show face with me together in Thuringia
against the brown unspirit um,
in the end today
also considers it permissible,
to vote with the AfD in the Bundestag
and that is with me so n point,
with which a limit is reached with me,
because I say um,
I don't want to,
that I am ever dependent on votes from the AfD
and I will do everything,
even to 01.09 this year,
if the Thuringian state elections are elections.
I will do everything possible to ensure that democracy wins.